welcome back to Facebook nonsense and
just stop oil protester become a
national irritation targeting all the
things that we love like sporting events
flower shows and so on one of the latest
processions was so delightfully met by
counter protesters staging an
intervention and the group just stopped
peeing everyone off also infiltrating a
just stop oil banqueting gloriously they
had balloons which flew around which had
alarms blaring off take a look
oh so fabulous isn't it interesting to
normal getting annoyed and irritated
just like they get to irritate and annoy
us so who is behind this and is there
more to come well you'll be unsurprised
to hear perhaps if your regular viewers
of the show that it's my old friends
Joshua Peters and Archie manners who
join me now are the world's top
pranksters uh great effort chaps I was
roaring you on when I first heard about
the first one I thought that's got the
mark of my boys and sure enough it was
you too
um you've taken me by surprise I didn't
think you'd be a fan of it so I'd rarely
relieved that you liked it I love it
because they are so annoying and in my
view the manner of their protests has
been completely backfiring because the
public are just seeing people setting
out to deliberately ruin their
day-to-day life that's not how you bring
people on the agenda with you right no
not at all I think we can all agree that
climate change is a very serious issue
and we all know that something needs to
be done but when you're protesting and
campaigning for things you need to bring
people with you and just stop oil are
having the exact opposite effect on the
British public and what you don't need
to do is have a soccer and great big
party on Sunday I mean that doesn't help
that does nothing to help the
environment at all it's just there was a
heart up there was a harpist live music
they're all clinking their single you
can't heard today that just policing
just up oil this year's cost over seven
million pounds now people are going
through a cost of living crisis seven
million pounds to police these idiots
who most of the time are doing idiotic
things I mean the other day they were
blockading a pregnant woman who was had
a uh who then her boyfriend got into a
fight with them I didn't agree with the
violence but I understood why he was so
defensive of his full pregnant uh
partner another woman had a newborn baby
in the in her car and couldn't take the
baby wherever they were going to go all
this kind of thing is just like to me
it's just moronic it's not achieving
anything and we in order to pull these
pranks off we had a mole inside so we
infiltrated their ranks and we followed
them around for a day before we pulled
any stunts and partly interesting was
talking to the police men and women who
hundreds of them on Parliament Square
policing this stuff they don't want to
be doing it either and they're so
irrespective also don't they've got
better things to do more important
things to worry about we all agree
broadly with the calls we just don't
agree with the methodology I don't think
it's changing people's hearts and minds
are you going to carry on doing these
chats I think we'll we'll call it a day
I think we've proved our Point
um look you know I don't think you
should I think somebody has somebody has
taken but just stopped paying off slogan
and whacked it on a website everywhere
they pop up annoying people you should
be annoying that appears on that note
we've brought you a little presence
Crystal wear this proud in fact you know
you know who I'm going to give this to
uh my my eldest son is watching tonight
he's big fans of you too he knows you
two from the nightclub scene no no we
deny that and it's 30 he's 30 years old
tomorrow which makes me feel
unbelievably old so Spencer uh if you're
wondering what your present is it's just
a ride and I know you'll love wearing
this you can take this to Ibiza where
you're going tomorrow so happy birthday
for tomorrow Happy Birthday 30 year old
son my God I never thought that though
he's really panicked about it as well
but I want him to join your group I
think they're a wonderful group to join
uh cheers well done thank you for
restoring a little bit of counter-attack
of his Madness and doing it with your
normal Panache and humor which is the
key I think uh good to see you both
thank you that's it for me what are you
up to Keep It Uncensored and remember
the key message tonight is this
just stop
peeing everyone off